retailleau votre réaction aux propos de
benjamin griveaux qui pointe à des
contre-vérités dans le rapport de la
commission denquête qu'il le démontre
depuis le début monsieur griveaux et et
d'autres auraient souhaité que nous ne
nions pas justement cette enquête là je
voudrais rappeler que s'il y avait eu
simplement le l'assemblée nationale
l'enquète ce serait close en quelques
semaines bien et bien heureusement qu'il
ya eu le sénat heureusement qu'en france
il ya des contre-pouvoirs et je pense
que ça c'est important pour la
démocratie
maintenant si monsieur griveaux dit
qu'il ya des contre vérités qu'il le
montre qu'il le démontre ce que savent
les français désormais c'est que au
coeur de l'elysée on a eu un individu
qui a avait un certain nombre de
relations avec des oligarques russes
voilà pour des gros contrats pour quelle
contrepartie je pose la question
ce que l'on sait aussi désormais c'est
que cet individu utilisaient des
documents en tout cas des passeports
diplomatiques pour rencontrer des chefs
d'état est ce que tout cela est normal
bien sûr que non donc notre travail et
nous c'est la manifestation de la vérité
c'est de faire en sorte qu' il ya des
recommandations qu'ils soient faites
pour que la sécurité au plus haut niveau
de l'état soit mieux assurée est pas
assurée par des gens qui ne sont ni
policier ni gendarme justement dans
cette affaire est ce que vous pensez que
c'est la sphère d'un individu ou d'un
individu c'est tout un système qui a
dysfonctionné le risque évidemment c'est
que l'on fasse payer comme d'habitude
les lampistes bien si monsieur benalla a
été au coeur de la sécurité du président
de république c'est bien parce qu'ils
avaient été recrutés
nous ce que l'on souhaite éviter à
l'avenir c'est que de telles erreurs
puissent se reproduire
j'aurais vous faire réagir à une
déclaration à que vient faire que vient
de faire à l'instant la garde des sceaux
nicole belloubet qui estime que dans
cette commission d'enquêté ce rapport on
n'est pas tout à fait dans le respect de
la séparation des pouvoirs
votre réaction ma réaction c'est que on
voit bien que l'elysée organise la
montée en puissance d'un certain nombre
de personnalités qui sont liées à
monsieur macro on voit deux ministres on
voit aussi bonne homologue à l'assemblée
nationale qui préside le groupe en
marche mais ça ne nous fait pas cillé du
tout vous savez nous on a des règles
nous avons fait condamné il ya quelques
mois
justement par parjure à un professeur de
médecine dans les mêmes conditions alors
il n'y a pas deux poids deux mesures
nous avons des règles et nous essayons
de les observer
c'est tout
de façon très rigoureuse mais je pense
qu'il faut des contre-pouvoirs en france
alors ensuite qu'on nous démontre s'il
ya vraiment des contrevérités mais très
franchement les français ont pu observer
le sérieux de la commission des lois des
rapporteurs et du président philippe bas
et justement sur cette question du
parjure le rapport pointe la rétention
de la vérité parce trois hauts
responsables de l'elysée alexis kohler
patrick strzoda et lionel lavergne et ce
qu'il faut être sévère avec eux c'est à
la justice de le dire maintenant vous me
madické que madame belloubet et posaient
des questions avaient des doutes mais
mamadou d est aussi la mise à la justice
elle devrait observer que la justice a
eu maille à partir si j'ose dire avec
monsieur b lada il ya une rétention
provisoire et on a appris en début
d'après midi qu'il y avait sans doute d
entrave à la manifestation de la vérité
donc je pense que il faut que les uns et
les autres puissent se calmer il faut
être serein
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on améliore
le fonctionnement d'un certain nombre de
points qui touchent non pas la sécurité
privée d'un homme parce que la sécurité
des mails macron c'est la sécurité
nationale et les choix qui sont faits ne
sont pas des choix privé ce sont des
choix publics
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya un
contrôle du parlement c'est tout c'est
la constitution c'est la règle
personne ne peut si j'ose dire y
échapper donc il faut se calmer à
appliquer les règles tout simplement
voilà je ne vois pas pourquoi on aurait
fait condamner un professeur de médecine
parce qu'il aurait menti sous serment et
que d'autres parce qu'ils sont puissants
ou parce qu'ils sont bien placés ne
mériterait pas le même traitement
on est totalement étranger à ce genre de
considérations